hello folks welcome to rational science
we have a busy day today so I'm gonna
get right to it we're going to be
looking at Extinction first doing a
little bit of physics then uh we're
gonna address uh an issue raised by our
science critic and then answer some of
the questions and comments that people
uh posted since last time okay so let's
get on with Extinction last time I
showed this a fellow um who
um one of the founders of um uh Home
Depot uh and his name is Bernie Marcus
and he said nobody wants to work these
days he says nobody works nobody gives a
damn just give it to me you send me
money I don't want to work I'm too lazy
I'm too fat I'm too stupid
so uh I guess uh he's a little
frustrated you know with all the um uh
people today that it's a different world
than the one he was certainly uh born
and grew up in you know and so what
fellow a couple fellows kind of answered
him and one fellow says no one wants to
work says says a guy who won't pay
enough to attract employees
uh I went to Burger Kind and and offer
them one dollar for a Whopper okay they
said no I guess no one wants to sell
Burgers anymore
okay and another foul says no one wants
to work because life is not fulfilling
there is no Community or sense of
immediate progress
laughs
okay yeah
um I guess if they gave people ten
thousand dollars a week
uh you know they'd be fighting for a job
at uh Home Depot you know but what
happens some people uh get welfare or
some other low income and if they work
they just get a little over that like if
let's just give a number uh let's say
you make a thousand bucks by being on
welfare and by going to work you can
make 1200 or 1300 bucks
well you know you may not want to go to
work
because uh the three 200 or 300 Buck
difference you know may not uh be enough
incentive for you so you would rather
stay at home and uh make the most of
your time in some other way and like you
know something useful like playing games
and I guess that's something that's
happening across the board today okay I
think there's a lot of Internet uh
activity and yeah a lot of people get
distracted by that they don't look for
jobs they don't go to work because it's
not worth it if on the other hand they
gave them two times three times four
times the salaries they're offering
today I think a lot of people would go
out and get a job you know
but again that's that's the status quo
today to some degree uh here's another
fellow says you talked about AI okay or
have you talked about ai ai should be
able to automate tons of service jobs
within a decade
so we're going to get rid of more people
from the labor force and uh let the AIS
even do a lot of the work we're doing
today assuming you know they can get
them running uh all these robots uh
running out well you know
um now guys as open AI already came out
with things like Chad gbt and dally2
it's Ubi or starvation for a lot of us
uh Ubi meaning Universal basic income
for those of you who are not familiar
that means you get a basic income and
you stay at home so again you know
they're kind of
um
giving incentives for people not to work
in many cases you know especially the
very low income why do they give them
incomes at all and the answer I guess to
that is because otherwise they'd be
breaking windows and burning tires in
the streets
you know crime would go up Etc but if
you give them some income at least they
say well you know rather than go to
prison or you know kill somebody or
whatever get hurt myself I might as well
go out there and uh and just get you
know the lowest salary and I can live
with that and I'll live within those
means and those are the type of
decisions a lot of people are doing
especially the new generation I would
think
okay so by why bother working yeah and
so I think this is a quite widespread
mentality
and um I'm not sure I can blame them
completely
again if uh you know and then you have
people in the country versus people in
the cities people in the country a lot
of people say you know these guys in the
cities they don't want to work
and yeah if you have a ranch out there
or some land and you say look I work
every day I plow you know I take my
shovel I do this I do that yeah if you
have a land to work on you might do that
but if you're in the city and live in a
little apartment you know you don't have
many choices available to you it's
either you know what Ubi or
um or you know get a job for a little
more than what you get from Ubi which
may not you know be worth it to you
another issue that a lot of people
raised um
several of them in fact
[Music]
um
is this notion that people have that
everything's a cycle
you know history repeats itself
and uh I guess we repeat history because
we make the same mistakes it's like we
didn't learn from the past we don't read
history or whatever and so our
politicians we everybody just repeats
many of the errors of the past and
that's why history repeats itself we
never learn our lesson that kind of uh
thought and that a lot of things are
Cycles you know like the curves if you
look at economics if you look at
population
Etc you know they go up and down and
people are so used to it you know we
have uh booms and crashes Etc so this is
what people have in the back of their
minds someone I talk to them about
Extinction and say look uh you know
that's a one-way Street they say no bill
it always goes up and down so it never
goes all the way down to Extinction and
at some point it comes back up they
don't know how they know when but they
know it's happened throughout history
and it'll always happen that way until
the end of
Eternity okay that's the way to look at
it and so here's one father and he says
the following if I can get them up here
so as people don't like working now
because they can get away with it they
they they can't get away with it so if
societies collapses and a couple of
billion people die of starvation the
others are not going to keep uh watching
YouTube uh-huh so uh we get rid of the
people who don't work and those that are
working they don't have to worry they
say Good Riddance right that's more or
less where he's coming from they will be
forced back into farming and racing
livestock we're going back to
agriculture
yeah I don't think so you know I don't
think we're going back to agriculture
but I don't we're certainly not going to
manufacture back to manufacturing and I
doubt very much we're going back to
Hunter Gathering even assuming we did
you know here you have eight billion
people almost and what would we be
hunting you know I mean there's not
enough
animals out there that we can kill
you know even by uh raising like cattle
and so on we have more population novel
these almost put together maybe not
chickens but yeah the bigger animals
like cows and pigs you know we're more
than them
and the reason we don't need more of
them is that we don't eat you know that
much meat on on the planet right we
don't eat as much meat as we should or
or we could let's put it that way
um in other words if we had uh eight
billion people you would think we would
need at least eight billion cows or
maybe even more and I don't think
there's that many I think we have fewer
cows and humans
just an example okay uh that can't
compete with a production rate of
industrial agriculture exactly so uh at
least there's no incentive to move into
the farm as a single farmer with its
tractors and chemical fertilizer okay so
another couple billion die so the
population goes down a few billion the
situation stabilizes and human life
continues on like you know no problem we
lost a billion people two billion three
billion good riddance uh people are not
going to just choose to starve to death
yeah people don't choose to starve to
that I mean if you want to kill yourself
there are better ways you can hang
yourself you can take a little pill
throw yourself over the bridge maybe ask
your friend to if he could put the gun
to your head or whatever there are
better ways of dying than starving
through that right but the point here is
that's not a question of choice it's a
question of if your forces starve to
death okay and uh and that's what we're
saying uh that's going to happen in the
case of Extinction uh there will be no
food now how's that for being forced not
to eat you know if there's no food you
know I'm sorry you will starve
okay another fellow also the all these
people who believe in cycles that
everything just continues on is always
it's just an up and down and Isabella
says the farm will continue long after
we're all individually forgotten or
perhaps deliberately erased uh yeah
maybe in a dilapidated Farm you know I
don't know
um
here uh here you have this uh this is
what I think is going to happen after
the Farms are gone after
Society collapses the the global economy
collapses survivalists Without a Cause
is just a what caveman he's just a
neanderthal that's all he is uh and
there won't be much to hunt and the
prepper you know all these people who
prepare for whatever they're preparing
Without a Cause is just a gardener you
need to have a cause you have to
understand what you're preparing for are
you preparing for just a little blip
you know some some uh accident that
happened of nature one of God's uh you
know acts of God
or are you preparing for the end
of man
the end of the world okay as we call it
and yes there you have a survivalist
after global collapse that's what he's
going to look like and prep her after
the glue will collapse that's what he's
gonna look like
and the only way they can survive is if
they live in some kind of community
family or several families or whatever
alone you will not survive aside from
the fact that you may not want to
survive alone because you know you won't
have any doctors
um you'll be quite lonely you'll
probably go nuts pondering you know what
happened to humanity there's a lot of
problems with being a lonely hermit okay
and so you got to think about all these
things okay and so here's uh what I
think will happen at least immediately
after the economic collapse uh those who
want to be Farmers they're going to be
Farmers by day and Soldiers by night
it's uh what the uh
Greeks called Hot Lights you know uh you
had to do both jobs you were Soldier and
farmer okay there's no such thing as not
having uh protection you need protection
I think uh Al Capone said that
any production okay so don't tell me you
don't need production yeah you're gonna
need protection from your neighbors
uh if you're I don't know in the middle
of Kansas you won't need to worry about
the Russians you'll have to worry about
the guy next door to you or the people
in the cities who we want to share in
your Bounty so you don't have to worry
about Chinese or Russians at that point
okay the enemy will be within
okay here's another photo who talks
about up and downs uh Cycles says uh
several States uh mentions right he says
are approaching a point where more
people are on unemployment welfare than
who are working this is unsustainable
exactly like all other Marxist socialist
schemes of the past failed so to two
will this one fail okay and then women
will naturally return to the kitchen
I think my wife would like to talk to
this fellow uh one-on-one face to face
and I wouldn't recommend that he go
there because he's going to go in there
with a gun
anyways taxing income directly has taken
the women out of a family structure also
women Liberation a government scheme to
get the woman out of the house and
paying income tax took her out of the
family structure it is all tied to a
natural cycle up and down up and down
and up and down okay so he thinks that
this is just a cycle of up and down and
we'll return to the good old days okay
we're going to return to the good old
days where
um you know women
uh go where they belong you know in the
kitchen
and men will go out I don't know hunting
killing and soldiering I don't know
um this guy is Out Of Tune with the
times okay we live in times of me too we
live in times of pronouns
and uh you know uh I've seen changes and
I'm from the 50s so uh you know I've
seen quite a few changes do I like them
all no of course not there's a lot of
stuff I don't like I just have to accept
the reality and these people are not
willing to accept the reality they want
to return back to the good old days
you know I don't know maybe to the days
of Charleston and uh you know rag who
knows
uh yeah they they uh have to really
confront the reality and the fact that I
doubt very much we're going back
especially to Hunter Gathering I cannot
imagine that at all okay that would be
uh you know a different planet Maybe
okay so uh follow says I think the same
thought the monetary system is crashing
yes correct out of its ashes
we will create a new system just like
has happened in the past again they
think all this is just repeating right
Cycles no monetary system has lasted
forever it is also tied to a cycle of
birth growth and Peak and death you know
here you have the phoenix bird coming
out of the ashes they think it's just
recycling everything you know
everything's a cycle
okay and that uh
we will repeat the past history repeats
itself we made mistakes we correct the
mistakes and that means we go down and
we come back up
this is what they have in their heads
they think uh somehow we're going to the
Past
okay and um
here's the same fellow says population
follows a cycle that goes up and down up
and down up and down your problem is
that you are thinking linearly rather
than cyclically okay the population
growth cycle is over we are in Decline
and will continue in Decline into
2039. I guess he's got a clear crystal
ball there okay however the cycle will
change again then aha nothing goes up
and down in a straight line
well uh there you have it up and down it
goes pretty much in a straight line you
know around a mean
medium whatever you want to call it
um I think this guy's been under seesaw
for too long
okay yeah I mean these fellows really
think that everything just repeats
itself history repeats itself and they
think Nothing's Gonna Change event in
the long run meaning there's gonna be
downs and we're gonna be in a sorry
State maybe we get into a recession even
in a depression but we'll come out of it
and we'll go back up
they don't know how they don't know
what's coming they don't know what's
going
needs to come after that right
but it's always going to be a cycle we
will never never become extinct the
thing goes on forever
okay
and uh so Saint Paul says the following
we have entered a climate cooling cycle
because someone asked them you know
what's going to bring the population
back up it says populations always
decline during these cooling Cycles
uh-huh Empires end as well so we will
see an end to the Western Empire it
remains to be seen whether we enter into
an Ice Age sometime in the 2040s I
believe we will begin warming again
there's going to be a warm cycle huh
maybe all that climate change right if
we do then we will see population going
up again however many believe there is a
12 000 year cycle and we may enter a
glacial period
so uh this uh for some reason thinks
that after the 2040s somehow maybe the
warmth comes back and I guess the people
will start procreating again there's no
mention of
um genetic diversity the fact that
humans have very little genetic
diversity and if a lot of people die
whatever is left we'll have less genetic
diversity the gene pool will be smaller
and if we're all in these pockets
you know 10 people here 100 maybe over
there at most
and you know that'll be the uh the seed
you know the um people who restart the
race so they're already going to start
not as we started out 200 000 years ago
with lots of genetic diversity we're
going to start now with almost no
genetic diversity from that seed okay
and uh whoever comes out of there you
know two three generations later will be
autistic homosexual who knows what
okay I I don't think we're gonna have
good uh solid
um genes two three four generations from
there on okay so even if Pockets survive
on planet Earth whatever comes out of
those pockets is not going to be good
that's assuming they decide to procreate
which is a more important more basic
issue of course they won't decide the
protein they're just going to live out
their lives if they survived the whole
collapse of humanity they're not going
to be procreating the last thing they're
on their mind that's going to be another
mouth to feed why would they procreate
another kid in a small community so that
he marries the girl across the street
and now they we have another Adam and
Eve situation
no that's the end of man hey be
realistic at least you know you use your
brain a little bit okay so no we will
not be procreating after 2040 officially
if we have a collapse of the global
economy and billions of people die
well it says uh same Pho says we are
looking at the extinction of our current
forms of government and Empire the
Republic 300 years ago the monarchies
went extinctly placed by republics okay
I guess he's talking to the French
Revolution about the French Revolution
right today the republics will go
extinct to be replaced by a real direct
democracies
okay
um
yeah all I can tell him has been there
done that you know uh
when I was 15 years old I got into
communism I that's how early I was
already into politics reading newspapers
books Etc
and it took uh 21 years until I was
about 36 that's when I started to change
my mind
yeah communism anarchism whatever you
want to call it they're all the same
really they all want this freedom from
government they say government is only
for the rich and we want a government
that's for all of humanity that sort of
thing
and uh we've never had that since at
least since uh We've created cities
civilization we've never had that
and so history does not repeat itself in
the sense that we never changed that
we've always had the same thing even
when Communists and revolutionaries took
over
you know uh it says you just replace one
king with another king they had
different names maybe you called them
republics or whatever it's always been
the same there's the new people they
became Rich they they began to control
the means of production and they and the
rest of the other people never made it
out of where they were that's that's how
it was always okay so um you know this
notion that somehow we're going to have
this uh uh what is it anarcho capitalism
that these people talk about today these
are the modern Communists that's all
they are don't call them Communists
because they get upset they're
capitalists but they want they want to
trade without the interference of
government
[Laughter]
yeah but the money they're going to be
using is you know from the government
and they have a lot of theories about
that but yeah you know I I can't even
begin to analyze that okay yeah there
won't be a world government or no
government whatsoever
uh in fact that was communism that was
the original idea the idea was all these
anarchists and Communists so show this
whatever you want to call them of the
19th century that's what they wanted
they wanted eventually to get rid of
government but first they needed to get
a hold of the means of production
through Revolution so you had all these
people they wanted to overthrow the
governments what so they could take care
of the they could take over the
governments and then you know taking on
its proper course which is in uh to the
benefit of the worker and at some point
they would decide well we don't need
government at all we finally can you
know everybody can rule themselves and
we don't need government we don't need
someone to tell us what to do
or who to trade with or what to do in
our everyday lives Etc
not only that never happen it will never
happen Okay Extinction will reach much
faster and much easier than that okay so
yeah I have abandoned all those thoughts
fortunately I woke up a little late
that's life
okay and so this fellow thinks that okay
who's going to take over the Chinese of
course because Western Civilization will
crumble right so it says yes China's
slowing down however China will turn her
production to selling to her own people
you know you got what 1.2 billion people
and she will become the new Financial
Center Postwood 2032. boy I wish I had
it crystal ball he's got all these dates
2032 this will happen 20 40 2039 this
other stuff 2040 the other good women
after 20 40 women will go back to the
kitchen
when the final Embers of the Western
Empire snuff out from the current Crash
and Burn
uh what can I say if uh Mr XI uh
premiere of China believes
that um China is going to go back to the
Glorious Days of West Genghis Khan I
think he's uh drank too much okay I
think he's got too many pink elephants
rolling around his head okay no it's
never gonna happen at least I doubt it
very very much okay I don't know how
China will get up there you might say
well it's growing look how much it's
growing in the last 50 years yeah and
here are the real values now and you
should look at the macro Trends before
you open your mouth okay here it is this
is China's birth rate it's been falling
uh since the 1980s even after the one
child uh per family policy uh was uh
removed it's still going down in fact
they don't need to do anything about
losing people uh growth rate you know
coming down because as soon as people
move to the cities
that's the end of population growth rate
to any country it's called density
dependent birth rates and China is in
that mode right now there's no way China
can overturn that anymore
the only way you could probably do it is
creating a new city in the middle of
nowhere
and for that you would have to create
some incentive for for example the new
population new generations to move there
and build a city out of nothing in the
middle of the desert
you know the year of colonization is
over we're going to make the existing
cities bigger the towns will turn into
cities the cities into megalopolis and
so on but we're not going to found new
towns
okay because for that uh it would have
to be like in the wild west you know you
go out there why because something
drives you there in this case it was
gold uh or land or whatever but that
that air is gone you know that was the
19th century in the United States China
also went through a period like that and
that's over now there won't be any new
cities on the planet maybe one somewhere
I don't know for some reason in general
there won't be any new cities I mean we
should be populating new cities
everywhere
Russia among others what is it their
population is dropping day by day
are they founding new cities will that
stimulate uh population growth it would
if they would if they could create a new
city now everybody flocks to the big
cities that's what's happening it's the
other way around we're making the big
cities bigger and the towns into cities
and The Villages into towns that's what
we're doing everywhere
and uh so this uh this is another chart
China's GDP growth rate by decade you
can see what's how it's gone since the
2000s it's been going down the growth
rate and so um
China's uh trend is to go down and China
will become like any other country that
uh industrialized
and eventually you know turn the corner
and its growth rate came down there's no
way China can grow forever at 25 like it
was growing like shortly after the days
of Mao Zedong
okay and uh here's uh the GDP breakdown
which I showed the other day the game
Services has surpassed manufacturing and
has surpassed industry I think it was uh
2014 2015 thereabouts that was like six
seven years ago and now
um now its services are even growing
more than industry so China is becoming
a service economy when it does its
growth rate will come down okay there's
no way it can continue growing at Big
percentages China has its name its days
counted on the almanac okay
okay another fellow says uh along the
same line that's a myth that we're
overpopulated only 2.7 of the world's
population world is populated with
cities we have a large amount of land
left on Earth
yeah and again it doesn't mean that
we're going to colonize those empty
lands of deserts those uh ice you know
ice boxes uh uh icebergs in the middle
of in the North Pole or in Antarctica
we're not going to flock to empty lands
there has to be an incentive for that
and for that but we don't need new lands
but what we need is jobs and if we could
create new cities we would be creating
new jobs and either one or the other is
going to happen
the problem is that we're packed into
these cities to make it seems like we're
compacted correct everybody flocks to
the cities not the other way around
nobody leaves the cities to go in the
middle of nowhere except if you have
some income you bought a house in uh you
know in the outskirts and you say well I
don't want the hustle and bustle over
the cities that is happening a lot of
people are moving out of the big cities
they're the you could say uh middle
class
and up not the poor people the poor
people flock to the cities and they're
going to end up eventually in the cities
living on welfare uh collecting the
basic income you know Universal basic
income
the truth is that the whole world's
population fit into Texas okay 65 of the
Earth has remained unexplored yeah well
that's not true uh we have satellites
you know uh I don't know if you knew
about that but there's not a single part
of the earth that we haven't looked at
through the satellites and there are no
lost tribes
none of that that that's a myth people
like to talk about lost tribes oh we
found a new tribe no no no that doesn't
happen we know every trap that's been on
the planet that is on the planet 65
remain unexplored okay 20 to 40 percent
of the Earth's surface has not been
affected by significant human activity
yeah and again it won't
we don't need it because the only way
you can get that uh activity in there is
if it's Justified and Justified means uh
economically otherwise nobody goes there
in the end there will be a cleansing of
uh the horrible humans and we will be
able to live in a utopian society
I like that so I'm asking will you be uh
part of the cleansed or the utopian
group
people are so sick of government that's
what's happening they're so sick of
government they're sick so sick of
politicians okay and uh well let me say
something about this uh what this fellow
said here let me just add this and
that's uh he's right about world
population
um you know uh
fitting into Texas but what he should
know is that the growth rate is coming
down and there's nothing we can do about
it okay so this notion that this other
thought had that after 2040 population
is going to explode because the heat is
coming back and etc etc now it's not
going to happen we're just going to go
down down down all the way to zero
population growth zpg and that's going
to be sometime around mid-century that's
the calculation today if everything goes
as it is going today I doubt we will
even reach zpg in 2050 I think something
will happen even before then but yeah
population will go down and there's
nothing we can do about changing that
Trend and a reason we can't change that
trend is we're moving to the cities and
in cities we don't have kids
so I don't care if you live in Palestine
or Palestine or in uh
China and India or the United States or
Canada or Australia there won't be any
more kids
especially the girls today they don't
want to have kids aside from the fact
that they live in cities everybody's
concerned about their careers that's
more important than having kids kids are
postponed until 30 40 50 years old
and then they come out wrong anyways so
uh there's very little chance that
population is going to explode back
again okay last year last time we had
high uh birth rate the highest birth
rate was in 1963 that was what uh 60
years ago almost and uh it was a 2.3
and since it's drop drop today we're at
one
and it's got to continue dropping until
we get to zero there's going to be one
person's born one person dies and then I
think we're going to go into negative
growth just like China like Russia and
Japan are negative growth all of Europe
Western Europe at least is in negative
growth population growth the only reason
they can more or less maintain their
population going is because they have
immigration that's the only reason
Russia can't do in Japan can't do it
because they don't have immigration
that's their problem
and they might change their rules there
as well because if they need to expand
they're gonna they're gonna need to
bring people from the outside that means
they're going to have to open their
borders
okay and that means a cultural changes
fighting you know racism all that kind
of good stuff
okay so um
file says regarding
um genetic diversity I said the other
day that we humans have very little
genetic diversity it says what are all
the actual studies about this inbreeding
you know because uh we have no almost no
genetic diversity among humans and here
was the let me show you the uh one of
the Articles out there you can look it
up and you'll find more of them but this
is the article chimpanzee populations
living relatively close proximity are
substantially more different genetically
than humans living on different
continents etc etc etc that was the uh
report that came out 2012 uh there were
a couple studies in fact and they showed
that humans have very little genetic
diversity what does that mean it means
we're all clones of each other if you
look at your genetic code your DNA you
compare it against someone else there's
not that much difference compared to
other animals you know
so it's a comparison kind of thing we
have a relatively little genetic
diversity much like the cheetahs
cheetahs not the monkey not Tarzan's
cheetah but the Cheetahs the uh fast
animal almost no genetic diversity
they're all clones
so and we're kind of like that we're not
as bad as the Cheetahs but we're we're
getting there okay and why because of
inbreeding so this fellow says you know
where are some studies and
um
all I can tell them is that there are no
studies uh I'm the guy who who proposes
that okay uh this is I put that in my
book uh how the Neanderthals disappeared
and I've got this uh chart there and
what I'm saying is
um mutation rate does not change is is
overruled is uh overcome by the fact
that we inbreed and then we have also
all these crashes you know eventually
right bottlenecks founder effects and so
on so
um you know I'm the guy proposing that
theory uh as far as I'm concerned no
geneticist on planet Earth uh even
discovered it or even imagined it I
don't think anyone who does genetics
even came across that idea the fact that
we've been inbreeding for 200 300 000
years and because of that we've lost our
genetic diversity that's the cause
that's the primary cause and people say
well we create you know mutations every
day new you know new new variations uh
those are overcome Again by or in the
past they were overcome by crashes you
know population crashes but uh just as
much as we create we destroy by
inbreeding
so this notion that people say mutations
take us in a better Direction you know
it's not not uh at least I don't
subscribe to that and I can give you as
my five cents peace of mind okay take it
for what it is
okay and uh fellow says the belief that
man controls the Earth's thermostat
Israel is a religion
uh I can't say controls okay I would use
that word
um I'm saying that
um
we do affect climate
in many ways by the crops we grow by the
fact that we do slash and burn we throw
coal up in the air we also breathe where
eight billion people breathing
uh you know all that has to have some
effect on the environment at whatever
scale you know that's up to people to
measure that stuff and determine exactly
how much we're affecting the environment
uh what I think is happening is that we
always have climate change we always
affect the climate every animal that
spin on planet Earth every plant that's
been on Earth
even one planet by a plant one animal
affects the environment as soon as you
breathe as soon as you consume air and
uh push out CO2 and so on you're
affecting the environment a small amount
but if you multiply that times many many
trees many plants many animals that's
got to have some kind of effect uh on
the atmosphere not to mention you know
natural things like volcanoes and plumes
coming out of you know the the waters
and so on so there's a lot of activity
and uh you know you have these carbon
and nitrogen cycles and so on that
changes my issue is not whether we can
affect
the control which is the word this
values control the uh environment I'm
not saying we control it but we do
affect it to some degree my quest my
issue with uh climate change is it has
no bearing whatsoever on anything
all those people talking about climate
change they're spinning their wheels
okay we got bigger fires here and the
big fire is our economy is at a dead end
it will be on the dead end quite soon
and that's what we got to take care of
and I don't think we can do anything
about it that's that's my position on
that but that's much more important than
talking about climate change climate
change even if it affects one two
percent uh one one two degrees or
percent whatever per Century changes up
or down you know colder or hotter
and it melts some ice and some animals
die that's not going to kill us so don't
worry about climate change okay it's
it's nonsense now it's good for
politicians because they say Hey you
know we can create some new jobs with
this stuff
and you know if we force everybody to
think about climate change we can create
industries that cater to the climate
change world
and you know create new technology put
people to work that's what it's got to
do with it's got nothing to do with the
environment per se in the sense that the
environment is going to kill us
that's what I'm saying okay I'm saying
it's got no bearing on extinction which
I think is right up ahead that's where
we're headed we're gonna hit a brick
wall
okay uh fellow says give us an idea what
money is I think he did a good job
pretty much so I'm gonna put this up
there it says money is created through
production
yeah
I guess you could call it value as a lot
of the anarchical capitalists like to
use that word value how much value does
it have you know money is a measure of
production
okay money itself has no value except as
a medium of exchange so far so good
everything I cannot produce everything
correct so someone I am uh bartering
with may not want what I have produced
and vice versa right as long as there is
someone producing something there will
be money
um yeah maybe you can produce something
for yourself without exchange uh but if
you produce it for with a purpose of
exchanging hopefully the other guy has
something to exchange with you the issue
is that when the whole world collapses
when the economy of the world collapses
uh the only thing of value will be food
and food you don't exchange
and therefore that's the end of money
anyways in fact it'll be the end of
bartering no kind of exchange will take
place no trade will take place because
the only thing of value is food food you
don't trade no hunter-gatherer change
exchanges food
but some people do believe that today
you know you have all these uh
paleontologists they talk about
neanderthals using money seashells and
whatever like John Hawks
my God okay and so uh here it is
um some these are some of the um quotes
that some famous people put up there and
uh someone sent it to me and so I
thought I'd put it up here this is uh
one phone and it doesn't matter who said
it uh just
uh keep your eye on what they said if
all money becomes worthless then so does
all government and all society and all
standards another fellow says under
conditions of famine uh it was the
farmers amazingly enough who were the
first to suffer often flocking to cities
that held stores of grain what were they
looking for
uh food and another fellow Mr Von misses
uh if inflation is not eliminated very
soon all our technological and
scientific improvements will not prevent
us from a tremendous Financial
catastrophe that will destroy
practically All That civilization has
created in the last several hundred
years in talking about inflation we
should not forget that there is the
danger that depriving the masses of
their savings will make them desperate
okay so yeah
um these are some quotes out there
people who in the past kind of saw
something was not right and they're just
trying to give you a word of caution you
know kind of a conclusion that they
reached on the issue of money so yeah
all I can tell you is money is very
important and I'll give you an example
here
and this comes from the Civil War there
was a
series created by Ken Burns a few years
ago a couple decades ago in fact and uh
you know you had uh General Sherman he
just went from Atlanta all the way to
Savannah
uh and he just destroyed everything in
his path he said War as hell you know
um and he said uh I don't think I'll get
the southern people to love me to like
me the women hate my guts in in the
South right they hate my guts
and I'm not going to convince him I'm
Gonna Change I'm not gonna change their
minds because they were born with all
this what I'm going to do is make life
so miserable
that they'll think again ever uh if they
ever want to solve things through War
don't engage in war with me he said
because I'm gonna make life very very
miserable for you and so he went down
from Atlanta all the way Savannah and
just wiped out everything
and you know then he went up north a
little bit and finally defeated uh was
it Johnson I think and uh who
surrendered you know and while he was
going he was destroying everything
especially Savannah he did a worse job
in Savannah than he did in Atlanta which
he burned you know took everything of
value destroyed everything else he did
something similar to Savannah and just
bombed every house to because that's
where the uh Civil War essentially
started or what they call the Betrayal
started and so some people were
suffering a lot what were the suffering
of were they suffering because you know
they didn't have their computers or
because their houses were destroyed
absolutely not and let this lady uh her
name was Mary Chestnut in the uh in uh
Ken Burns um
documentary
and this is what she had to say listen
to her because he tells you something
about money
okay so those of you who think that
money is forever and money never will
lose and people will always accept money
listen please to Mary Chestnut this is
what she had to say listen carefully
we dread starvation far more than we do
Grant or Sherman famine
that is the word now
I daily part with my raiment for food
we find no one who will exchange
eatables for Confederate money so we are
devouring our clothes
did you learn something
nobody would accept her money
was not an issue I can't use that money
I don't want it anymore I want food that
was what was undermined after Sherman
went through there and destroyed
everything
and that's more or less what you got to
look forward to when the global economy
collapses meaning money will be no more
okay uh not a prediction it's got
nothing to do with prediction okay I'm
not giving you a date or anything like
that I'm saying that all mass
extinctions happen be because the
economy collapses to any animal all
animals have economics all animals
manage resources the primary resource
that any animal
uh on the planet uh including us manage
is food all the rest is
nonsense papika we don't need it we
don't need houses we don't need beds we
don't need any other what we need is
food then you live one more day
okay uh so one Falls does Extinction to
you mean that there will be no human
left on Earth
yeah exactly uh Extinction means when
the last human dies okay they have all
these movies like you know I'm Legend
and Waterworld and so on and they have
lots of these first of all it's
interesting that we have so many of
these movies in the last couple decades
it's like people have this sixth sense
that something's not right that's one
issue that's I think why they become so
popular but uh then in all these movies
you know it never ends in Extinction it
always ends with a woman having a baby
and they say oh hope
not here
I want to make sure I give you no hope
whatsoever
okay and people say Bill you're so
pessimistic what a pessimist
uh no I'm not a pessimist you know I
drink beer I drink wine and I don't
drink it because uh you know uh I'm
pessimistic I don't drink it to get
drunk I drink it because I like it I
don't get drunk but
um
aside from that you know I'm realistic
I'm trying to tell you what's coming up
okay and all you can do is get used to
it okay uh uh or maybe adjust your life
in such a way that you factor it in
there you know maybe you're in your 20s
and you believe that you're going to get
Social Security someday
all I can tell you is think again
you know so you're contributing to a
fund from which you will never get a
penny out of okay that's one issue but
the other issue is that maybe you got to
make new plans okay
uh for your future
and another fellow says finally he says
if we really work at it we might be able
to take all life with us
okay and here you see what you can call
part of the sixth math Extinction okay
which a lot of people say we're
undergoing right now all these animals
have died they can get the percentages
and so on there of a lot of these
animals that have disappeared in the
last few hundred years okay
and what can I tell you yeah we're we're
in the midst of a mass extinction that's
on the one hand uh some people say we
crowded a lot of these animals out
others say we over hunted them whatever
the case I'm saying a lot of them died
because they were simply old species so
they died on their own without human
intervention whatsoever uh maybe we ate
it in some way by crowding them out yeah
that could have happened but primarily
they died because they were old species
and
uh you know I think we're already in the
uh in the sixth math extension for some
for hundreds of years probably but uh
when we go
we're gonna probably wipe out every
mammal anything that walks on land at
least I think it'll be wiped out all
bears are lions uh all cows uh all birds
uh maybe a lot of fish I think we're
gonna wipe out a lot of the living
entities out there because we're going
to try to survive we're going to kill
anything that's walking out there
including other humans
so uh yeah we're gonna take everyone
with us especially the mammals This is
the End not only a man but also the
mammals just like the dinosaurs went
away the mammals will go away in this uh
instance as well
let me say the following you know for
those of you who are not familiar with
my Extinction Theory
someone comes to you and says
uh will humans ever become extinct
and you might answer say
um well yeah I mean in the universe
might become extinct you know matter
according to relativity right is
expanding uh the universe expanding it's
becoming uh less dense as time goes by
thinner and thinner you know the this
the debris that's out there floating in
space and yeah probably uh humans will
die somewhere in those days unless they
come up with something new and say we
Wormhole to another Universe you know
they might even come up with that but
that's trillions of years put trillions
of years down the down the road I don't
have to worry about it
okay well you know that the Sun
is about to expire blow up maybe in 100
200 300 million years depending on who
you listen to depending on calculations
well yeah but still I don't think I have
to worry because you know again that's
millions of years down the road
well how about climate change you know
that might happen within the next
thousand years and we might have all
these catastrophes on Earth etc etc
so yeah I mean if it happens anything
above 100 years I don't think I'm
worried too much because it won't affect
me I'm sorry it'll affect my great
grandkids but not me and I'm sorry for
them
and uh how about if I say that maybe in
the next 10 or 20 years
we will become extinct
and now it's getting closer to home you
know and now you might wonder well what
do you mean
how fast what could happen in the next
10 20 years that will kill me I mean
we've already ruled out the sun we ruled
out you know uh climate change what is
it peak oil uh Disease an asteroid
what's going to kill us
and that's why we need as I say we need
to determine what causes a mass
extinction what is the cause
because we're talking about Theory here
you're talking about we're not saying
it's going to happen on the first of
July of I don't know the year 2035.
we're not saying that we're saying look
at the mechanism and based on that you
can get an uh intuitive feeling how much
time we really have left
and what do we look at well we look at
first how did the animals in the past
die did they did the dinosaurs die
because of an asteroid strike or did
they die of something else
um that's one issue the other one is
let's assume we figure out what they
died of are humans able capable of
overcoming that
um same issue that same mechanism that
same uh agent
with all the technology with uh all the
knowledge we have all the um
um foresight that we have we have the
ability to look into the future and
calculate and imagine and say uh perhaps
you know that um
hey man I hope I'm still online because
I get a message there from YouTube
uh let me know otherwise anyways uh you
know what is the uh what is the cause
if we figure out the cause and we can we
figure out that we can't do anything
about that same agent that same cause
that same mechanism
then we figured out you know what's
going to kill us
and if we can figure out uh you know how
soon that mechanism will occur
you know we can look ahead maybe we can
have an estimate of when we really think
we're going to die when the last human
will you know succumb to whatever will
die
and so I think it's important for all
people to look at uh that those that are
interested in the subject because you
know if you figure that out that uh we
won't live thousands of years hundreds
of years we may have only a couple
decades at most left in our lives
well maybe it changes your way of
thinking maybe maybe today uh you were
thinking about you know oh I'm not going
to throw this gum that I have on the
floor because that's going to mess up
the environment
you know so I got to take care of the
environment because you know it's not
right to do that
but if you know the world is going to
end in 10 or 20 years or you reach that
conclusion well maybe you don't care
anymore
and you say well what the hell you know
I'm going to throw this uh gum anywhere
because that's not important at all
anymore
and if I'm not going to collect Social
Security I better make some other plans
and so you know your mind changes if you
know you've only got 10 20 years to live
you know it's like that movie The Bucket
List
um
I think it was Jack Nicholson and uh you
know these two old folks they had only a
few months to live that's what they were
told by their doctors and they said what
is it we want to do and how they created
their bucket list right uh in the last
few moments of Our Lives
those terms if you think Extinction is
going to happen
okay
let's move on to another subject which
is not Extinction which is distance
we're gonna do a little bit of physics
okay
and um
uh distance distance is a static concept
and I talked about it a little bit the
other day when I was doing the um bid on
the universal movie so I'm going to
start there a little bit because
um
it leads us it's the introduction to
what I'm going to talk about today which
is distance okay and this is what I
showed I showed you know that we looked
at the universal movie and we look at it
as uh each frame as a static image
uh we have all the all the atoms in the
universe there in front of us and they
all have and it's like if we can stop
each frame and look at it and all we
have within each frame is just distance
location existence you know it's just
static Concepts okay and that's the
notion in other words uh we rolled the
movie forward and we have different
locations in different frames of that
movie and we're assuming God can stop it
he's all powerful that he can do that
right
okay so that's the notion of the
universal movie it's a tool okay the
tool is so that you can look at each
frame individually and see what is there
without having any motion whatsoever not
even an electron moves in God's movie
This is the universal movie not the one
you hold in your hand those are made out
of atoms the electrons are still moving
there in that frame that's not what
we're talking about a lot of people get
confused with that we're talking about
the universal movie we're talking about
everything being at a certain location
with respect to everything else
and that's a static Universe a frozen
Universe there's nothing moving in that
frame okay
again I get a
I get a message that uh
I'm not that you're not receiving enough
video I hope I'm still online okay and
that you can hear me fine okay
anyways
um
uh here's a fella and he says uh what is
a static concept
and I think it's about the question
static concept is one frame of the
universal movie whatever you can
conceptualize there it's got to be in a
single frame that means that the word
that we're talking about does not
uh involve two frames of the movie
there's no motion okay and so there you
have some examples of the word object
the word shape the word distance none of
these uh involve uh motion none of them
involve two frames of the universal
movie you can conceptualize for example
Edge
without uh having two frames in the
movie you can conceptualize
perpendicular
without any motion whatsoever so these
words are static Concepts in contrast we
have Dynamic Concepts and they require
at least more than one frame of the
movie okay
thank you
okay
um so so what's the issue there you have
some uh Concepts okay Dynamic Concepts
such as you know field energy plasma
I've discussed some of those in the past
time electricity Black Hole uh geodesic
interaction force all those are involved
motion the word involves motion the word
itself is defined in terms of motion
so you have Concepts which are static
which involve no Motion in the
definition of the word itself and others
that involve motion that uh embody
motion okay so that's the difference
between
um a static and then Dynamic concept
when I talk about those terms
hope that clarified that because also
the same fellow says there is no such
physical presence as a cross-section of
time
all physical presence is in motion
always time is this constant changing
locations
okay and of course they try to get that
plasma stuff in there their electricity
in there they and their field in there
they want to get all these Dynamic
Concepts and they want to put them in a
single frame of the movie
and you can't do that because all these
words are defined uh
with uh motion embodied in them
that's the issue so you cannot
conceptualize Force without motion
for example or geodesic without motion
okay all these embody motion okay
creation the word creation you know just
coming out of my head creation involves
some kind of motion okay exist on the
other hand existence
no motion whatsoever
income in contrast right okay so uh yeah
uh fellas they rebel against the uh
Universal movie because we are able to
in one frame to stop time stop motion
stop any kind of movement
uh it doesn't involve two frames of the
movie in a single frame everything is
just has distance with respect to every
other atom in the universe nothing is
moving they don't like that because
uh it destroys their religion they want
to use words such as plasma electricity
field energy as things and these words
do not represent things because they all
embody motion it's like I say they're
all jumping kangaroos they're not
kangaroos they're jumping kangaroos
they're running boys they're flying
birds
swimming fish they're moving already
and they don't like that because they
say look let me tell you my theory I
don't want to hear your theory
I want you to show me what's in the
first frame of the film
and he said plasma is in there now you
can't do that because plasma defined as
ionization as an ionized atom and that
requires motion there's a phase there
which is another issue and here we get
to the phase to the next phase here we
have state of matter and phase of matter
is called synonymous
God says
well uh no state
is a static concept there is no motion
involved in the word State the word
state does not embody motion the
definition okay and on the other hand
phase does
you know you can't imagine phase without
change because that's what phase is
and here is uh here are the definitions
for these words okay let me put them up
here phase bearing modes or conditions
phase a stage in a process of change
what is a stage a single step in a
process that would make it a single uh
frame but then says a for a particular
phase
period in other words again they they
have all these words mixed up because
they Define them as single frame and
then they Define them as two or more
frames
and so they never settled settled the
issue of phase and that's why people get
confused with these words they say no if
this is a single frame in the movie well
it is and it ain't that's one issue then
you say State and it says the condition
of a thing look up conditions as
particular mode of being of a thing
existing state existing state would
qualify for a single frame but being
does not sound like a single frame and
yeah the the issue here is that we're
using words of ordinary speech that have
never been defined and of course when
you get to these issues you try to
Define them people say no you're
destroying my religion you're raping my
Virgin you're killing my gods I was
going to use electricity to tell you my
theory I was going to use plasma to tell
you my theory I was going to use field
and energy to tell you my theory and
we're not going to allow them because
you got to show me the object you can't
show me the object already in motion and
say that's my first frame
that's the problem that these people
have so they don't like
the universal movie uh tool because it
stops their frame and it forces them to
identify what's inside each one of those
frames okay
and so the spelling simple the main
difference in the structures of each
state is in the densities of the
particles in solids the particles are
tightly packed together
uh-huh and so we look it up and it says
and I say ask him the following
questions is the ideal cube of geometry
a solid
okay think about that is a Cuba solid I
think if you asked um
Euclid he would say yeah uh Cube belongs
to solid so does sphere cone and
cylinder and others
is the cube made of particles
or is a cube made of a single piece
isn't the cube conceived to be perfectly
smooth
how about the sphere the cone the
cylinder right are they smooth single
piece or are they rough and made of
particles
okay so you got to answer those
questions okay is a cube a solid and if
it's solid the geometric cube right
geometrical Cube then now you can't talk
about made of particles because the
ideal cube of geometry is not made of
anything it's made out of a single piece
conceptually
okay here's a and it belongs to the
solids right Paul says same fellow okay
it says in liquids the particles have
more movement
[Laughter]
we don't know whether a liquid is going
to move before you define the word
liquid
okay why don't you begin there liquids
don't have to move in order to be
liquids
is milk a liquid is water a liquid is
oil a liquid
uh do they have to be moving to be
liquids
where in the definition of these words
is there a provision for movement
and the same applies to gases okay so no
uh none of these uh words require motion
I can point to a liquid on the floor
it's not moving okay and it's not
because it's moving or not moving then I
call it a liquid
and point the milk on the floor there's
no movement and it's still a liquid
hopefully okay and again you gotta
resolve these issues
father Sir Bill doesn't want to discuss
the psychology of different temporal
analogies this analogy fails to
incorporate the fact that things change
and persist reality isn't constantly
flickering on and off for the next frame
the analogy neglects the persistence
continuance of things that a thing can
change
the analogy is coming from film so it
inherits this blinking off of reality
for a new distinct one constantly
these people have this uh notion that uh
motion is continuous time is continuous
right this is this is what's behind
these uh Concepts that these people have
going through their minds
and so you say well uh what is motion
let's Define motion
and we Define it as two locations or
more
location is a static concept location
fits in a single frame of the universe a
movie
and so what these people are thinking in
the back of their minds or this is what
they have up there attic is that hold it
between two frames
there's motion
because motion is continuous
well so is the universal movie I mean
you can chop up the frames between two
locations you find a million more
locations gazillion locations put them
in there between any two locations
there is no motion because motion is two
or more locations
so we have to define the word Motion in
order to be able to talk about this
intelligently you can't say between two
locations we have all these motions
because that's the mathematical concept
the points of Infinity of numbers
between two points between two numbers
right
for example on the x-axis of the number
line right they have these two numbers
and they say well I can chop that into
gazillions of numbers which is the
notion of point they say there's
infinite points between any two points
this is what they have in the back of
their minds
and so the universal movie kills all
that
because suddenly you say look I don't
care how many
uh frames you have between two frames
in the Universal movie because
everything is static and then the next
gazillions of a second quadrillionth of
a second what do you want
uh
I I don't even know a bigger number than
that uh there there's got to be two
locations one next right after the other
in fact
let me put it to you that the
um what is it called the um uh plank
time
okay the plank time is the smallest
interval of time according to the
mathematicians out there they say it's
the smallest interval of time you can't
have a smaller interval than the Planck
time
so that's good enough for me I don't
have any problem with that I think it's
nonsense but I'll I'll go with a plank
time that means that from one location
to the other
okay there is no thing smaller than the
fact time I cannot have anything closer
to my first location than the length of
the interval called the blank time
so we'll work with playing time that's
good we'll call the plank Time Each
frame of the movie of The Universal
movie from one plank time to another
plank time we have two discrete
locations
there's nothing in between those two
locations and this blows her mind away
because they say no no I need to have
motion I need motion I don't want to
stop the universe
which is another issue what if God came
in there and stopped the damn universe
I mean he's all powerful
you don't like God you don't believe in
God no problem we'll stop the universe
anyways
I'll just wait my magic wand whatever it
is I can't find it anymore
uh imagine wave my magic wand the
universe stops we all stop Frozen in
Time
what do we have in that frame of the
film what do we have in the universe at
that specific cross section at that
specific stop sign
we have location we have static Concepts
that's all we have we have everything at
a distance from each other just Frozen
in time no time no motion just locate
just static concept location Etc
I thought I was being cut off again by
YouTube okay so this is the issue that's
what we're talking about okay so here we
have God
and uh he's in heaven he's in the a
different dimension okay and he's going
to stop the universe at frame number 32.
okay that's so we we all stop we're all
Frozen in that frame there's only
distance there's only location there's
only existence in that frame okay here
it is this is all you have there
let me put this up there okay that's all
we have in that frame
okay object distance location existence
any other static concept that you want
that's all we have in that frame because
God has stopped the universe okay or
maybe the universe stopped all by itself
no motion for whatever reason magic okay
what do we have in that frame we have
only static Concepts among them distance
okay distance is a static concept we
don't need to have anything in motion to
have distance
and that is going to be part of the
problem of the definition of distance
okay but here let's continue here we
have the Universal movies made of
locations
plank links okay no problem uh plank uh
time no problem
we'll call each frame a plank time how's
that is that does that solve your
problem there's nothing between two
Planck times because there can't be
anything because that's the smallest
unit of time according to the
mathematicians but I like better to say
frames of the movie because that gives
you a better idea that everything is
just Frozen in each frame you can
identify all the objects at that point
and certainly you won't find Plasma in
there you won't find force you won't
find energy none of the Dynamic Concepts
ether you know none of that
so his location the static concept
when you have location it does anything
move
when you're thinking about location you
know what is location location is a
static concept there's nothing in motion
when you talk about movement or motion
there is it's a dynamic concept
something is moving but when you talk
about locations right there Frozen in
Time Frozen in motion
so this location involved motion
absolutely not IS location a verb
do you need two frames of the universal
movie to conceptualize location or can
we do it in a single frame
okay uh is uh motion constructed with
locations what is your definition of
motion that's what you got to tell me
here we have the definition very clear
it's two locations or more than one
location
we're done
blank times no problem if that's what a
frame is we'll call it plank time we'll
call it whatever you want but I hope the
notion gets through to you what would we
end up with if the universal movie were
to stop
location or motion location or time well
what do we end up if if suddenly the
universe came to a complete stop
and yeah people say well I won't be
thinking I won't know no no we're
talking about conceptually here try to
use your brain sometime okay we're
talking about conceptually what would we
end up we would end up with only static
concept because motion has been outlawed
time has been outlawed suddenly we have
a frozen universe everything is simply
at a distance from each other all we
have is distance between objects
okay so uh here we have location is the
set of distances motion on the other
hand is uh more than one location
okay so uh you can see in the top one
the we want to know what the location of
a cube is well we look is a separation
static concept from uh the cube to
everything else in its vicinity in the
universe whatever nothing is moving in
that frame on the other hand and motion
on the other hand you can see that the
kid has two different locations with
respect to the cube so we call that
motion because we have at least two
locations of the boy
okay makes sense we can use these words
consistently now scientifically
rationally
and this is what the mathematicians have
they have uh position you know use
location to use the word position what
is position does it is it a some kind of
Separation like do you see distance
there now you can see both position and
distance are synonyms because position
and distance are measured in meters
centimeters feet
yards uh kilometers miles
their their synonyms position means the
same thing as distance
in in mathematics and here you see why
okay let me remove this guy
okay yeah they're the same words
position distance displacement and
length maybe there are other synonyms
out there they're all the same concept
in mathematics everything is in motion
they don't understand anything that's
not in motion because mathematics Deals
Only with motions mathematics has no use
for qualitative Concepts static Concepts
such as existence
it's just the word exists belongs
exclusively to physics not at all to
mathematics mathematics doesn't care
they what they want to do is
calculations equations numbers
and when they talk about position
distance displacement or length what
they're talking about is measurement
they're going to be measuring something
in this case we see the uh the uh man
there he's measuring or putting tiles
from one block to another block
okay so all he's doing is counting tiles
measurement they call it and so length
is brief read from the box distances
repeat from the box displacement
positions are all the same they're all
synonyms that's how a mathematician
visualizes these words
and people don't always pick up on on
these subtleties these qualitative
Concepts Dynamic Concepts okay so here
we have it we look up the word distance
to find out what distance is in the
religion of math mathematical physics
actually math is is a language but
mathematical physics is a religion
because math cannot be reconciled with
physics no way know how one has nothing
at all to do with the other so the
mathematical physics is a uh an oxymoron
self-contradiction okay so here we have
distance it says look it up into
Wikipedia says may refer to a physical
length
you look up length that says is a
measure of distance
oh man we learned a lot there X is equal
to Y and Y is equal to X
what do they call it the identity law or
some nonsense like that
we look up another source it says
distance the length of the space between
two points and it also says distance is
an integral of time a distance for
example of six years so they have all
these Notions which they Bunch up they
mix them all up and they say distance is
all of these all of the above
here you have another site says distance
is the total movement
of an object without any regard to
direction we can Define distance as to
how much ground an object has covered
despite its starting or ending point
so they think uh it's about measurement
about uh movement it's about
um you know putting tiles on the floor
rolling your measuring tape from one end
to the other they think it's all about
motion that's what distance is and you
can see that distance and length are
synonyms because one is defined in terms
of the other
and uh the dictionary got it right
apparently to some degree it says
distance the extent or amount of space
between two things points lines Etc
right the problem here is that distance
is not an amount
so if uh if uh mathematics mathematics
or the dictionary defines distance as an
amount or in terms of the word amount we
got a problem there because distance is
no amount of anything then the other
problem is that even if it were or if
the extent of space between two things
which sounds very qualitative even if
that were the the definition uh
mathematical physics never used or used
as this definition at all so it would
not matter because no one uses that
definition in so-called science modern
science contemporary science the science
um that follows a scientific method from
the days of uh Galileo and Newton
okay
okay so uh here is what uh these people
say essentially just from the Wikipedia
distance is is a what numerical or
qualitative measurement
right of how apart objects or points are
so they think uh distance is not really
distance they think it's distance
traveled because they're going to unroll
the measuring tape they're going to
count tiles predetermined tiles could be
a meter it could be a foot could be a
yard could be a kilometer they use these
tiles that are already predetermined and
they're going to put one right after
another and say oh it's so many
kilometers so many miles from here to
there
and that's what distance is it's
measured in units predetermined units
right such as meters centimeters feet
inches whatever
and again it's a synonym synonym of
length because length is a measure of
distance right length is a quantity
with Dimension distance
what is dimension distance what kind of
Dimension I mean they just mentioned
these words it's like they're talking
absolute nonsense there's no Dimension
called distance
but that's what they call it Dimension
distance so they have infinite
Dimensions because weight is the is a
dimension uh you know the color of your
hair is dimension everything's dimension
uh so they defined it so broadly that
the word Dimension loses its value life
is the most extended dimension of a
fixed object now we do not extend
Dimensions at all we leave them quietly
because all they are is qualitative and
a dimension is something that is
perpendicular to
the other two so we have length is
perpendicular to width and height that's
one issue and the other one is not only
are they perpendicular they're straight
they're only qualitative and the only
other property they have is Direction
that's it it's all qualitative there's
no measurement we don't extend them we
don't stretch them we don't do any of
those things that mathematicians do
okay so um
here we have uh the distance of physics
versus the distance of math
okay distance of physics to separation
what is the distance of math well the
guy's counting tiles
and until he finishes counting all the
tiles
we don't have distance
we still owe are counting tiles we're
still unrolling the measuring tape you
know
or maybe clocking it you know because
we've already got the standard made up
and we say well so many seconds is so
many so much distance because we're
going at a certain rate that sort of
thing right so you have all these
measurements and they call that distance
but that's not distance that's the
distance traveled of math the distance
of physics is just separation
uh there's a separation between the
Earth and the Sun there's a separation
between the Earth and Jupiter and the
Moon Etc
there's only separation that's all that
mother nature understands Mother Nature
doesn't understand feet inches and none
of that that we've invented
and we go to another planet they
certainly have different units okay
find intelligent people hopefully not
like you're on Earth
and uh so all that mother nature and
father Universe understand is separation
that's qualitative that's all they
understand we have to figure out how
gravity Works how uh you know uh
magnetism works because we have these
things separated we need to find out you
know what's happening in between in that
separation in that Gap in that distance
that we have between these two things
and we do not need to know how far apart
they are if they're one meter or two
meters that's not going to tell us
what's happening inside that region
the numbers are not going to tell us
anything uh physi math cannot tell you
many things and let me tell you one
thing that math cannot tell you anything
about with other calculations on you
know they they boast so much all these
mathematicians they say oh we know we
know we can calculate we can predict
okay
and uh one thing they cannot predict
is existence
they can now tell you what exists
okay they cannot tell you with an
equation with a number with a number
line with any calculation of any sort
sets uh any anything that you can
imagine from that you cannot predict
what exists
okay so uh keep that in mind uh
equations cannot tell you what is out
there okay mother nature she knows
what's out there if there's something
invisible and intangible in between two
things she knows it's there we don't
because we can't see it or touch it and
an equation is not going to bring it to
light it's not going to tell us anything
about what's in there for that you can
only drink a couple beers and visualize
then you can maybe figure out what could
be in there that mother nature is using
to fool us
that's the way you do it but to say that
oh I'm going to do an equation I'm going
to run an experiment
what equation what experiment you got to
run
if it's intangible and invisible and the
equation is not going to elucidate
anything for you not going to reveal it
for you
okay so here we have some of the
problems that we end up because distance
has not been defined properly in other
words defined as distance traveled
instead and you get to all these
irrational things that we find out there
in the literature
and that goes into blogs and which then
trickles to the masses out there here's
the first one okay what is infinite
distance one guy asks and I think it was
this wasn't quora okay
infinite distance guy answer says means
the separation of masses Beyond which
there is exactly zero gravitational
force
that's infinite distance okay
um so I guess if you go around Infinity
you know in a circle in a figure eight
Loop
you have infinite distance right because
you can go around that forever right
that's infinite
uh you're also in a circle or any any
closed uh figure like that right you can
travel forever
uh according to math you've got infinite
distance meaning distance traveled
but distance is the green lines there
according to physics you know you can
measure it in any direction you want
even in in a slanted mode of some kind
you know skewed uh but there you have
two examples the green lines there are
two distances from one Edge to another
that's distance separation
so none of that is infinite there and uh
so these people say look there's
infinite distance meaning the infinite
distance traveled because you can go
forever in along that figure eight
okay so we have these infinite distance
uh the other issue is that if you go
even in a straight line right
to the edge of space-time and there you
have a couple situations one where they
say well you loop around come back to
where you were I mean you can go on
forever in circles which is what the
mathematicians do but let's assume you
go to the edge of space-time assuming
there is an edge it's got a finite you
know some kind of surface or whatever I
don't know what's outside of that don't
ask because they say it's International
question but you get to the edge of
space I'm in a straight line well then
it's finite
but if space-time is explained expanding
you know blowing up big bang and it's
been blowing up for 13 billion years or
whatever
then yeah then that distance keeps
growing and growing growing on you and
you can say you have infinite distance
whatever that mean means distance
traveled not distance you're not saying
look conceptually I have a certain this
a certain separation with the edge of
space-time you're not saying that you're
saying I'm going to travel and as
space-time grows I'm going to have
infinite distance because I'll never get
there
you see the problems that this creates
here's another irrationality comes out
of distance and it's uh I need the ID
effect you know he says that there's
something called length contraction
and you say well that's length
you know it's not distance contraction
is it it's length contraction but why
because length is distance distance and
length remember they already settled
that distance is defined in terms of
length and length in terms of distance x
equals y y equals x the identity law or
whatever they call it okay so uh yeah we
have a distance contraction here uh
length contraction
and you say look uh this guy travels
close to the speed of light and his
ruler contracts in the direction of
travel
and so we have problems because they're
not talking about distance they're
talking about distance traveled
okay but at the same time this distance
traveled is shrinking your length
which apparently is not the same thing
as distance which they say it is
so you figured it out okay that's one
problem
okay let's let's go with uh similar
problem this is my solution to that
problem actually you know uh my
suggestion of how to show whether that
length contraction is real because they
say when you end up again in your uh
frame of reference uh your ruler goes
back to normal or to you it never
changed it only changed so the guy who
was observing from the outside when he
comes to your area the ruler's back to
normal so we can't prove that the
uh ruler shrunk
but here this is my my test for that
said here you have a and b in the case
of a you have this uh Planet you could
say whatever could be an asteroid
whatever flying through the air through
space it travels close to the speed of
light just a little below the speed of
light
and we have an object could be a
cannonball could be another asteroid or
whatever and it's going to hit that
object which is driving it close to the
speed of light
at that point there where they both meet
so there's they're both going to meet at
this Collision point it turns out that
if there is no real length contraction
of the object that's traveling close to
the speed of light which is the big ball
there well then there's going to be a
collision
what B shows over here on the right is
that if it does shrink
you know in the direction of travel uh
well we have a problem because then the
um what is it the Cannonball or whatever
is going to hit it doesn't hit it
because this thing contracted in its
direction of motion
okay so this is if we could show
something like that we could run an
experiment to show that it would debunk
uh the nonsense of general of special
relativity okay
so uh again this is just uh one of those
uh thought experiments that might help
clarify in your mind whether what these
people are saying is rational or not
but um
then we have a problem because again
what contracted was it length was it
distance well remember the muon we
talked about a couple weeks ago
well here we we don't have length
contraction we have distance contraction
and the question is you know they never
analyze whether the muon itself
contracted the little ball did it
flatten out in the direction of travel
see they say it's a particle that does
not have any internal structure it's an
elementary or fundamental particle it's
traveling and they say the distance
traveled uh the distance contracted and
we said well did it was it the distance
of separation or was it the distance
traveled that contracted is the number
of frames in the movie where some of
those lost is that what happened we
squashed them below the plank time is
that what we did or was it that the muon
itself because it travels close to the
speed of light contracted the little
ball became flattened out
you see all the problems that we create
by making distance equal to length and
it turns out they're not talking about
either length or distance they're
talking about distance traveled and in
the case of the length contraction
they're talking about unrolling the tape
and measuring the length meaning we're
talking about the distance traveled of
the tape
and they say the distance traveled of
the tape shrunk meaning length
contracted on the ruler right by
implication by you know extrapolating
and what they're saying again is that
some of the frames are missing in a
universal movie because everything else
in the universe is normal they have
distance with respect to each other but
in in case of the length contraction the
distance contraction what they did was
eliminate some of the frames of the
universal movie somehow
meaning it disappeared in some of those
frames because all the frames should be
there for everything else so if the
um
muon itself had some of the frames
disappear that means the muon
disappeared from the universe and then
came back when the next frame was
available
okay uh it's or or vice versa uh some of
the frames disappeared of the universal
movie from the
um
muon uh distant traveled some of the
movie of the muon some of those frames
of the universal movie are missing
so this this is where the universal
movie is a good tool to analyze all the
nonsense that comes out of special
relativity as far as their conclusions
their physical interpretation
especially when they tell you that
they've proven it through experiments
okay
okay let's move on to our um our science
critic
see what he's got to say today okay and
uh so essentially he's gonna argue that
science is not objective
meaning I guess it's not rational it's
subjective that means that it depends on
your opinion
I'm not sure what he's saying so let's
let's listen to him let's see what he's
got to say listen carefully here goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
the subjectivity play any role in the
explanation of a mechanism
is simulating light with discrete
particles and opinion
and is explaining gravity as warp
space-time a physical interpretation or
a belief
science can't really be objective yes it
is the closest thing that we have to
objectivity but it does have flaws if
science were objective then it would
have no flaws if science is objective
then science cannot be wrong science can
be wrong therefore science is not
objective
okay so he said science is not objective
because science does have flaws there
are some things are proven false I guess
that's what he's talking about you know
that's what he's got going through his
head
okay let's address his issues let's look
at him one by one science has no flaws
maybe he has flaws uh maybe I don't know
he's uh lived in the ghetto and the bus
didn't take him to the east side of town
where the universities were or these
colleges or high schools maybe he went
to a monastery I don't know
um science rational explanations that's
what science is physics rational
explanations of mechanisms causes and
mechanisms that's what we're interested
in physics we want to know how gravity
Works what causes gravity to work the
way it does why does a pencil fall to
the Earth to the ground to the floor
and here science is only science when it
is fully comprehensible
okay so if it has flaws maybe it's not
comprehensible
we're not talking about wrong or right
which is an opinion we're talking about
I give you an explanation of something
of of a mechanism of how a motor works I
don't know or even of gravity what
causes a pencil to fall to the floor
where's the flaw
I mean one thing is that you don't
believe that's the way it happened we're
not talking about that we're talking
about what is the mechanism I explained
to you a mexism say that all atoms of
the pencil are stuck to every atom of
the earth that's why it falls down
because he
um
um as the pencil gets closer to the
Earth all the ropes
uh come out of the single uh
axes in which they were and they fan out
and that's what brings it faster and
faster rate because you have more what I
what we call more effective ropes each
one is uh acting independently that's
the point it's not a question of belief
it's a question of do you understand the
mechanism that I'm proposing and I'm
giving you a rational explanation
where's the flaw
okay and so
um only if it's fully comprehensible if
you comprehend it then you say okay I
don't believe in it but where's the flaw
flaw means that you're going to give it
some subjective interpretation
religion has flaws why because religion
is opinion belief knowledge truth fact
proof conversion recruiting persuading
you know all that stuff is religion you
don't do that in science
so simulating light with particle is
that objective
you know quantum mechanics simulates
light with particles
uh they're not real particles but let's
assume they're real particles okay so we
have all these particles like they used
to have in the 19th century you know the
ether
and these particles move straight As
Newton and vision done
and so he gives you an explanation she
says look all these particles move
straight that's my simulation of how I
simulate light
fine I understood it it's comprehensive
what he's saying is comprehensive do I
believe it that's a separate issue but I
can understand what he's saying
uh his mechanism is is straightforward
so it's not a question of belief it's a
question is did You Understand the
mechanism that Newton just finished
explaining to you that's the issue
believing that light is actually
mediated by particles that is what is
subjective uh simulating God creating
the world is objective
you know you get God and you may moves
his magic wand
and increase the universe
okay I see what's going through the
guy's not mine the guy who's giving the
presentation
he says look God did Abracadabra he did
a magic trick and suddenly he created
the universe
I understand what he's saying
I may have problems with the mechanism
of how we went from the universal movie
frame where God is there with nothing
and then the next rain suddenly the
universe appears I mean him run with
that you know uh he kind of violates the
what plank time
but uh other than that I have no problem
I understand what the guy's saying it's
objective he's saying look here there's
a universe uh here's no Universe with
God and here's a universe with God
okay I might have problems understanding
the intermediate steps but other than
that I understand what he's what's going
through his mind that's objective
believing that God made the universe
that's a separate issue that's got to do
with religion in fact one fella here
summarizes quite well and he says the
following
a belief has absolutely no Credence in
scientific method absolutely
a belief can be true or false right
that that's why we don't accept it in
science or in the scientific method it's
an acceptance that a statement is true
exactly that's what a a belief is just
an acceptance for you that it's true
that it's a fact a theory is an
explanation uh for An Occurrence right
a theory may not be correct
when in science we do not judge we do
not vote okay for theories there are no
um
experts in theories all we have is
people who give you their theories their
explanations their mechanisms so that
you understand them you don't have a
person who's saying oh that's right and
that one's wrong
that we don't have in science okay so we
have no peer reviewers in that sense the
pure the function of the peer Reviewer
is simply to tell you whether it's
irrational
whether the theory you put forth meets
the criteria of the scientific method
not to tell you whether it's wrong or
right or whether it matches what all the
other mathematicians voted for
none of that has anything to do with
science okay that's known as religion
that's opinion so correct is a question
of opinion
uh religion is belief correct religions
are belief based acceptance yeah that's
why uh we do not accept belief in
science belief has nothing to do with
science it's purely religion and Truth
is believing you already have it
absolutely God all of those we could say
right that's my opinion
uh my point here is that he synthesized
uh that uh What uh science is versus
what religion is okay uh you want to do
religion do believe and talk about facts
truth knowledge
uh what's been proven all that's
religion in science we only explain so
that you understand the mechanism of
Christian physics right philosophy
something else but we give you a
mechanism you understand it we're done
it's got to be comprehensive it has to
be rational there's criteria for
rationality it's got to be an
explanation there's a definition of
explanation so you should have no
problem in identifying all that
okay so yeah this uh fellow I don't know
where he studied
uh he certainly uh lacks uh
you know quite a bit of understanding
of what science is about
okay so he learned all this stuff that
you know the the rabble out there learns
and he just repeats it parrots it
so yeah no uh in in science uh we do not
confuse it with religion it does not
have to do anything but belief and
therefore it is not subjective science
is objective always because it's got to
be comprehensible and it's got to be
rational and we do have definitions for
that
okay let me get to some of the comments
questions people raised a couple of them
here one fell says fields and energies
have shapes
poor fellow uh I don't know what he's
talking about shapes how can they have
shapes okay so um
here we have uh
okay uh what this was really missing he
missed the definitions of field and
energy field a quantity that has value
for each point okay and energy is a
quantitative property a conceptually and
mathematically useful property as it is
cons as it is a conserved quantity all
that out of the Wikipedia so both field
and energy are quantities quantities
hopefully don't have shape so I don't
know what this fella is talking about
shape okay but it's interesting that
they went out there and some people try
to give shape to uh to some of these
things these these words right and
here's one uh this is one notion of
energy that when foul had out there or
one group had out there that's what they
drew that's energy there you see you
always want to know what energy looks
like there it is it has shape right uh
whatever that is
I don't know if it's uh angel trying to
become come into our universe right
here's another picture okay this is from
a site a professional site puts a light
bulb that's energy as far as they're
concerned okay and here's another one
okay
this is also the professional site and
here's energy I guess it's the black
stuff or maybe the stuff that's around
it is that energy that's what energy
looks like is that the shape of energy
here's another one okay
and uh it's in the Wikipedia so you can
find it there and it's that uh blue
stuff that's coming into that ball I
guess I don't know if it's molasses or
some syrup or something like that okay
so yeah uh you figure out what the shape
of uh energy is when all these people
are talking about different shapes
illustrating different shapes
okay so what is the shape of energy and
that's Just Energy now here we go with
field okay this guy says field has shape
here's one field in the Wikipedia looks
like that a bunch of arrows curved
arrows
I guess the Indians shoot the arrows and
they come around I don't know to the
Cowboys
uh could be you know maybe a bunch of
arrows I don't know what are we staring
at is that a field here's another field
but these are straight and all these
field uh looks like they're moving
radially I guess they're moving I don't
know because this is supposed to be the
shape of a field
okay so I have no idea what this is just
a bunch of arrows is that what a field
is and here's another one uh
it looks like a funnel okay
maybe it's a toilet
so that's a field now you know what a
field it looks like that's the shape of
a field all these fields and energies so
yeah field energy if they're quantities
now you cannot illustrate them they
don't have shape otherwise you would be
able to illustrate them and say like you
illustrate a table or a rock or a tree
but here you cannot illustrate these
these so-called words okay because
they're Concepts
okay uh follow says
uh you keep saying plasma can't be seen
in a single frame but uh X and Y are
images of uh of embedded in unicode
well I don't know what this poor fellow
has going through his brain I mean
plasma is straightforward but we don't
even need to address what he's talking
about there plasma is ionized gas okay
it's not standing still because it's a
process of I constant ionization
otherwise you don't have plasma if you
take a snapshot of that what you have is
not plasma because plasma is defined as
ionized gas is a process so you cannot
put a process in a photograph okay and I
don't know if that got through to you
but yeah I don't know what uh this is
driving at what you have there in front
of you is plasma uh an illustration you
know and as you can see it's in motion
nothing is standing still looks like a
beehive
and that's what uh plasma is a beehive
it's constantly in motion
okay and here's the final one for
tonight and it says the following says
we can't stop the concept of time yet
they say imaginary black holes stop time
I like that uh that was good uh yeah uh
time stops at a black hole black hole
that's what they say and so uh all these
people who say that there's something uh
that you can't stop time you can't
freeze the frame well they should look
at a black hole because that's what the
mathematicians do they stop time at the
black hole there's not uh not that the
frames stop moving it's that they're no
frames at all there's no time no
anything in there black hole is zip
that's what uh black hole is so yeah I
like that because a black hole stops
time and a lot of these people say you
can't stop time in fact the shortest bit
of time is with the plank time
okay with that I'll see you on Sunday
and uh please uh put comments there and
I'll try to address as many as I can
okay let's